on va tourner aujourd'hui un clic ça va
être passée entre autre vie
[Musique]
ça va être génial
et moi je vais stress parce que je vais
débuter par une scène assez sensuelle
attendus salle de bain je vais dans las
une fille comme toujours c'est cool ça
s'est très bien passé j'étais très
naturel
j'étais très serein très spontané et la
sensualité
si le clip over rouge qui va donner
envie de refaire un clip en fait tout
simplement cette fois avec maxence
j'apprécie énormément maxence médiatique
sur sa chaîne sous le tricot il a
vraiment un truc qui chante super bien
il à son délire à lui est en fait quand
j'écrivais cette chanson j'imagine et
déjà avec maxence
je suis très content quand il a accepté
qui a donné son go ça m'arrive de placer
les principales places ont produit c'est
plus des opus pour la sortie d'un jeu en
fait que je fais ça mais pas de vrais
placement position que j'ai jamais fait
d'évoluer à son produit
tu
tournon
là actuellement j'ai un gros de la poule
aux oeufs oui c'est le son qui fait
comme ce gars est prêt on assure d'être
ici youpi ah non un long moment ça c'est
le graphe ok carrefour à merde des
annonces et celui là soit tu sais c'est
le mien le jeu c'est celui-là c'est un
grade ou tuent violent h et coûte cher
ans
[Musique]
moi ce qui m'énerve c'est qu'ils
rigolent pas nos blagues signaux très
simple un guillaume sait qui c'est qui
doit pas parler ses jambes entendre sa
voix ou super se sentait pas de retour
et on voit bien sûr faire le bridge le
bridge c'est quoi c'est la révélation
on découvre notre communauté en a marre
de ce qu'on fait en a marre des
placements de produits et on décide de
tout en même temps un problème en
question
ils ont formé en place dix ans je crois
qu'on a un problème
pas question du coeur
en fait moins en moins du les gens c'est
la bonne non c'est pas vrai tu auras
qu'on a fait une connerie en fait on va
mettre la musique en faux double quête
de sens pour que caen
quand on fait la gueule oui c'est
beaucoup plus entre eux explique ont
fait tout en vitesse fois de pur montage
diviser le rush vitesse ford s'était pas
car toujours en place sa mère à fond les
ballons tu m'as à fond les ballons on
est à fond les gondoles ça n'a pas
impossible de mesurer son plaisir
qu'elle imagine chose qui n'est pas fils
ouais ça se passe super on s'apprête à
faire la chose la plus cool du clip
poussé des gens dans nos jours d'un
congrès
bon
[Musique]
et
c'est un autre jeu concours donnez
quelques chansons et on peut jouer
maxence avec sa gorge
voyez la réponse sur sept les 108 118
100 de s'en aller
sommes actuellement en train d'être
posés sur un beau thème avec meego hôtel
les objets les pétoches je traite
passage attention attention le hockey
[Musique]
with
m
assis là
[Musique]
oh
oui
je acheter mais ce samouraï ça donne
cette puissance sam de la force
where he will tu le sais
[Musique]
voilà il faut bien noter c'est la base
et son bébé ça te pleurer sa licence à
vie
or ce ton d'alger
[Musique]
c'est pas grave je fais un ton
légèrement pourquoi comme ça c'est après
un fois que je le sais pour un projet à
moi ça sur septembre prochain sont
conscients que c'est avant tout celui du
cac et moi moi d'habitude je pense juste
une caméra avec un pote à moi qui me
cadres et j'ai juste des idées de lieux
de base
je me fais mon stylisme tout seul et
justement on part dans la nature quand
on dépend et c'est pas qu'il y ait
réalisé à l'avance c'est beaucoup non
non moi c'est vraiment un fait lâche
donc c'est vrai que ça change
mais les deux sont en hauteur g genève
[Musique]
expérience incroyable et on pense que ça
aurait votre odorat maximum en temps dès
lors à mexico où ça fait mal nous a fait
mal jouer dans le dos j'ai pas mal là
j'ai mal j'ai mal nagé
c'est un an est prêt il arrivé jeudi
dernier
[Musique]
on a réussi à bientôt pour d'autres
aventures incroyables
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec la pole à bientôt et merci à
brouilla énorme pouces murale sur un
making of je remette un pouce bleus tu
croit souvent fait un truc c'est vrai
stations émettant au maximum et on vous
regrettera le dos toute la journée parce
qu'avec nuno douilles ont tous mes biens
comme le jardin de la famille